[Music]
on melwater's property in the manastash
Ridge West of Ellensburg Washington
there's a hole in the ground that looks
like a well but it's not a well like the
owners of the property before him Mel
used the hole as a trash dump his
neighbors used it too garbage broken
appliances old tires everything went
into the hole after a while Mel started
to wonder why doesn't it fill up and
then he started to notice other strange
things about the hole his dogs wouldn't
go near it it caused His Radio to pick
up strange signals and it didn't seem to
have a bottom Mel's curiosity became an
obsession let's see if we can get to the
bottom of Mel's hole
foreign
Pitt nine feet nine inches in diameter
there's a stone retaining wall built
around it that goes down about 15 feet
after that the hole extends down into
darkness well not only did Mel Waters
and his wife dump everything in the hole
but so did his neighbors and this has
been going on for a long time for years
before Mel even moved in Mel's neighbors
said they couldn't remember a time when
the hole wasn't there so why can't you
hear objects hitting the bottom why
can't you hear your own Echo Mel set out
to determine exactly how far down this
hole goes an avid fisherman Mel had
spools a fishing line on hand so he
attached a one pound weight to the line
and sent it down the hole it went 4 500
feet the full length of the Reel and
didn't hit bottom he reeled the line up
attached a roll of Lifesavers and set it
all the way down again Mel wanted to see
if there was water at the bottom and if
there was the Lifesavers would come up
dissolved but they came up dry and Mel
had more spools of fishing line each one
five thousand feet he attached another
spool now down almost ten thousand feet
and still no bottom spool after spool of
fishing line went down the hole he could
not reach the Bottom by the time Mel ran
out of line he was eighty thousand feet
down over 15 miles and still no bottom
while experimenting Mel noticed that his
dogs wouldn't come anywhere near the
hole even when forced the dogs would dig
their feet in there were no animals of
any kind near the hole no Wildlife no
insects birds even flew around it and
since the hull was known to his
neighbors Mel asked around if anyone
noticed their dogs feeling uneasy by the
hole they all said yes then one of his
neighbors said speaking of dogs not too
long ago his dog died so he threw its
body into the hole
a few days later that dog came back
after Mel's neighbor threw his dead dog
into the hole why
why I don't know you can't bury it I
really I really don't know sometimes
humans are very disappointing they
certainly can be anyway a couple of days
after disposing of his dog's body down
the hole he saw it running through a
wooded area near the property that he
knew it was his dog because it was
wearing the same collar but for some
reason the dog didn't come when he
called the dog acted like he didn't know
his owner at all oh maybe it's a version
of his dog From Another Dimension well
that's definitely a theory as the weird
stories piled up and the fishing line
kept going down Mel was at a loss he was
out of his depth
right Mel needed help figuring out
exactly what this hole was and in 1997
there's only one place to discuss the
strange and mysterious and be taken
seriously Coast to Coast AM with Art
Bell from the high desert and the Great
American southwest by visual good
evening and or a good morning wherever
you may be across this great land of
ours Coast to Coast was on hundreds of
stations around the world and had 10
million listeners if anyone could help
Mel it was Art Bell and his audience Mel
sent art a message on February 21st 1997
art called him and Mel's Hall became
known to the world over the course of
several shows Mel Waters would reveal
more and more details about the
mysterious hole the good news is Mel was
getting really good advice from people
all around the world like use a laser to
measure or use radar to check the
distance the bad news is now millions of
people knew about this hole and from
Clues given by Mel on the radio you can
get a pretty good idea of where it was
the day after the first broadcast
Mel was returning to his property but
the entrance was blocked the government
yep the U.S military was now aware of
the hole and they wanted it all to
themselves
[Music]
uh after the show on Friday night it
went out there and uh and uh noticed uh
there were some some helicopter activity
around the property
those further helicopter activity the
next day
uh and so I figured that uh clearly
somebody out there listens to your
program all right Mill said that the
hole could affect things in the
environment around it animals avoided it
but plants seem to grow extremely well
radios acted weird if Mel brought a
radio near the hole the signal would get
very staticky and then start picking up
broadcasts from somewhere else one day
His Radio started picking up what he
describes as old time music
so he goes to change the channel and
tunes into a baseball game
's first baseman
[Applause]
until he learns the game was played in
1967. 30 years ago Art's first call with
Mel goes on for about an hour and then
they wrap up Mel is staying in
Ellensburg for a couple of days and had
made the call from there when Mel Waters
returned from town the access road to
his property was blocked by armed
military personnel and there was
evidence that heavy machinery had been
brought in Mel was told there was a
plane crash on the property but there
was no report of a crash no fire no
smoke still Mel was told he couldn't
access the property until the crash was
completely investigated when Mel asked
to speak to the person in charge a man
in civilian clothes told him that the
land was not necessarily his anymore and
it would be very easy to find a drug lab
on the property if he didn't leave Mel
threatened to go to the Press
The Man In Charge Man in Black the man
in Black told him go ahead and talk
nobody would believe it but Art Bell and
his audience would believe it and a few
days later art called Mel for an update
Mel said that a neighbor saw a dark beam
coming out of the hole and up through
the clouds darker than anything he'd
ever seen now Mel admitted he didn't see
this himself but Art Bell and several
callers said that this part of
Washington has a lot of UFO sightings
disappearances and other Paranormal
Activity callers had their own theories
maybe the hole was sitting on a Ley line
and there was a portal to another
dimension or it was a portal through
time and that's why everything thrown
into it disappeared maybe somewhere in
an alternate reality there's a big pile
of garbage old appliances and dead
animals just piling up who knows one
caller thought this could be a tunnel to
the hollow Earth oh like a subway for
lizard people
something like that there were a lot of
theories and since Bell couldn't access
his property anymore he talked to other
locals trying to get more information an
elderly neighbor said that many years
ago there was a series of stone columns
around the hole inch right but without
the cross beams which are called lintels
lentils lentils what I say
someone from the audience reminded Mel
that calling into the show is a big
mistake because obviously the government
is listening so the show ends and Mel
agrees to come back for an update on the
day Mel is scheduled to reappear he's a
no-show and not picking up his phone
maybe my audience is not aware but a
television crew
went up to Ellensburg after we did the
last program
and uh researched this and I'll be
doggone they didn't find the hole but
they did find uh near the area where you
were talking about a lot of military
Blueprints and all kinds of uh
information that would indicate military
in fact had been there or was there oh
they would have probably seen a lot of
yellow gear tread marks in the ground
it would be three years before Mel
resurfaces he said he was offered three
million dollars a year to Lisa's
property to somebody but the deal was
sign a non-disclosure agreement leave
the country immediately and never come
back so Mel takes the deal and he lives
in Australia for two years but he's
missing his family and decides to come
back to the States for a visit not spot
it wasn't Mel was warned not to do this
but he does it anyway and during this
time he gets in touch with Art Bell and
agrees to come on the radio but he never
shows up Mel said on the day he was
supposed to to come on he was on a bus
to visit his nephew and on the bus there
was some kind of altercation and the
police were called all the passengers
are questioned and put on a different
bus then no blacks out
and the next thing he remembers is that
he's in San Francisco and 12 days have
passed Mel woke up in an alley his
wallet and keys were missing he realizes
his arm hurts he rolls up his sleeve and
there are needle holes and tape marks
from an IV and as he becomes more Lucid
he tastes blood in his mouth his back
teeth are missing Mel never makes it
back to the property there was legal
action taken against him for illegal
construction power lines septic tanks
paved roads of course he didn't build
these the government had occupied the
property for two years still Mel lost to
everything and a day or two after
calling into art show his bank account
was emptied now to be fair plenty of
people are calling in saying that this
is all a hoax but Art Bell is the master
hoax or not it's a great story so he
lets Mel continue but art does say that
a TV crew was in the area looking for
the hole they didn't find it but they
did find evidence of a lot of military
activity and the no-fly zone has been
mysteriously expanded to cover the area
in fact Terra server which was a mapping
site before Google Earth showed that the
whole area was blacked out and this was
confirmed skeptical callers said that
Mel could have found the blacked out
part of the map and pretended his
property was there the problem with that
is Terra server launched six months
after Mel made the first phone call he
couldn't have known soon we learned that
a Native American tribe had contacted
Mel and asked him if he wanted to come
to Nevada and help them research
research what another bottomless hole
[Music]
foreign
they took you to it they took me there I
was I was not I did not go all the way
up at all but there was conversations
between uh the Native Americans and The
Basque and the blah blah blah and it
basically uh
uh agreed that you know everything was
as it should be that I wasn't you know
from CNN or the FBI or CIA right
whatever uh and so I went there and uh
uh I got to see the hole now what's
there
the second hole wasn't located on the
Indian Reservation where they lived it
was actually on public land that was
used by Basques the baskar and ethnic
group that comes from a small region
between France and Spain The Basque
settled a couple of areas in the United
States including Nevada in the mid-1800s
they were using this land to herd sheep
they told Mal that the hole was there
for as long as their people were so at
least 200 years and they consider the
hole and the land around it sacred this
hole was just over nine feet wide just
like Mel's but where Mel's hole had a
stone retaining wall of a few feet the
second hole had a metal collar and metal
lining down as far as the eye can see
and this hole was warm to the touch you
could feel heat all around it and the
metal wouldn't make any sound or vibrate
at all Mel accidentally dropped a tool
on the metal collar and the impact was
completely silent so Mel and The Basque
begin their experiments the first test
was they lowered a bucket of ice down
into the hole about a thousand feet and
they kept some ice at the surface as a
control when the surface ice was melted
they brought the bucket back up that ice
didn't melt at all and even stranger the
ice was no longer cold to the touch and
it wasn't wet the ice felt like large
pieces of salt so they tried to melt the
ice over an open flame it didn't melt
did it nope it caught fire not only that
it continued to burn for months so they
continued sending different amounts of
ice down the hole about two-thirds of
the time it melted normally but one
third of the time it was transformed at
this point one of the braver Basque
volunteered to go down the hole himself
what is he nuts yeah everyone agrees
that's not a good idea so they decided
to send down a sheep a sheep oh what
happened to the Sheep
oh no
[Music]
well I just felt I was in the presence
of something extraordinary something
Beyond extraordinary something like in
that category of having a religious
thing there this was just such a
stunning thing to witness the Sheep did
not want to go in the hole the closer it
got the more it tried to kick its way
out of its crate they lowered the crate
down the hole to one thousand feet at
that point it stopped moving they felt a
humming sensation they left the Sheep
down there for 30 minutes and then
brought it back up there was no movement
the crate was unchanged and the Sheep
looked fine but it was dead The Basque
being Shepherds knew how to butcher a
sheep so they brought it to a table for
a quick autopsy oh [__] right now what
are they doing the first thing that they
noticed is that the Sheep looked like it
was cooked from the inside and taking up
almost the entire cavity of the Sheep's
body was what Mel described as a giant
tumor then the tumor starts moving what
oh
this is intense then they cut the tumor
open no inside the tumor is what Mel
describes as
fetal seal wait wait did you just say a
fetal seal yeah like a baby seal it was
attached to the tumor by an umbilical
cord but this seal-like creature had the
eyes of a human they watched the
creature for a while as it crawled to
the end of the table and Mel felt like
it wanted to get back to the hole so he
picked it up and set it near the edge of
course the creature was slimy and Mel
said that the fluid had the smell of
ozone so the men studied the creature
and it seemed to study the men for about
two hours then the seal creature gave
them a final look and jumped in the hole
now before Mel went to Nevada he was
diagnosed with Advanced esophageal
cancer he had only six months to live
but after this experience Mel was
cancer-free he thinks he was cured by
the magic seal
yep Mel felt like he had a Transcendent
experience he was completely changed
after this and just then the radio show
runs out of time no
[Music]
no
across from me over here
is the actual roadway into Mel's hole
don't go up that road up their ways his
offense but uh you get across that fence
here in that deep bunch of trouble it
might be that you simply disappear
period a few months later Mel returned
to Coast to Coast something crazy
happened with that bucket of ice
remember one of the basks took the
burning ice to his cabin to keep warm he
had it in a stove it burned for months
and it was pulling all the moisture out
of the air the air in the cabin was
always dry the owner's skin was always
dry he was constantly thirsty when
boiling water the steam would be pulled
into the stove one day the stove crashed
through the floor and into the ground
under the cabin but it was still warm so
he patched up the floor and used the
hole for warmth a couple of weeks later
he's returning home and his entire cabin
has collapsed and turned to dust he
moves in with his brother for a while a
month later he comes back to the cabin
and sees that the stove is now five feet
underground and the hole made by the
stove was perfectly smooth it was making
a new baby bottomless hole it was and
they couldn't get the stove back up it
took a giant crane to finally get the
stove out of the hole and at this point
the Basque said they were sometimes
visited by The Entity that they
discovered in the hole the magic seal
yes the magic seal
they felt it was a benevolent presence
and considered the whole experience to
be very spiritual there are now brightly
colored birds circling the hole birds
that seem to be immune to bullets that's
how they respond to a spiritual
experience shoot the birds I guess
freaking bisque The Basque even believe
the magic seal is communicating with
them over the radio using a system of
beeps and clicks as language which they
can understand the creature warns the
bask that the ice is dangerous and can't
fall into the wrong hands and would lead
to the destruction of the planet art
asks if there is a recording of this
language there is the Basque recorded
everything for the next hour a few more
theories are considered and art finally
gets Mel to agree to come back on the
show but this time he would bring the
recording photos video and everything he
can get his hands on Mel agrees to go
back to Nevada and gather all the
evidence he hangs up and the show ends
Mel is never heard from again he doesn't
respond to Art's calls and eventually
the line is disconnected so after five
years the story of Mel's hole finally
comes to an end but it left so many
questions
[Music]
there are a lot of Art Bell highlights
and Mel's hole is right near the top so
how much of the story can we confirm
first the location of the hole Terra
server did black out that part of
Washington but on Google Earth it showed
back up but if the military really had
taken over the property they would have
covered up the hole people have been
searching for it for years and of the
many locations I found there was one
that was really compelling this is the
Google Map
someone actually went to the location to
see what was there these are the
pictures
during one of his phone calls Mel said
there were two old buildings on the
property and one of them eventually
collapsed under snow this fits the
description pretty well and also on the
property is this yep a hole about nine
feet wide with a stone retaining wall
exactly how Mel described now this
caused quite a stir online but the hole
turned out to be an old well and
definitely had a bottom if you search
the internet you'll find a lot of people
claiming they found Mel's home they
haven't it's never been found at least
not yet as for Mel he's a complicated
character there's no record of a male or
Melvin Waters living in the area but
some have claimed he was using a
pseudonym to protect his identity that
makes sense now something that really
hurts The credibility of the story is
the lack of pictures in every call Art
asks for photographs but sometimes Mel
just doesn't think to take a picture he
forgets which is ridiculous another time
he says cameras don't work near the hole
because of interference or he does have
pictures and recordings but they're not
handy so he'll send them when he can but
in Mel's defense he never plugs anything
even if this is a hoax he could have
made a fortune selling T-shirts books
phony photographs anything people would
buy that stuff just because it's cool I
would buy a Mel's whole t-shirt I went
to Mel's hole and all I got was this
magic seal fetus yeah that part of the
story was pretty wild and that's a
common argument that Mel's story got
crazier and crazier and eventually he
just couldn't keep up with it so he
bailed on the hoax but he was pretty
consistent with the facts over five
years and Art Bell tried many many times
to trip him up and he couldn't do it now
the hole itself just isn't geologically
possible a whole many miles deep would
be unstable and collapse in on itself
unless it was a bottomless hole to
another dimension right unless it's that
but I don't think we'll ever know Mel's
hole has many Believers but I don't
think art Bello is one of them but art
was an Entertainer and this is the type
of story that his listeners loved it's a
legend that people still talk about 30
years later but for me in this channel
this was a master class on how to
present an urban legend let the story
breathe but still challenge the
specifics explore the mystery but keep
it grounded be critical but
compassionate I try to approach topics
this way but very few others do a
channel that tells mysterious stories
without giving all the facts we'll get
more clicks and it will get more
subscribers but that's a shame because
it's dishonest and you deserve better we
all do
foreign
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share today's
story was a request from you and if
you'd like to suggest a video go to the
yfiles.com tips special thanks to our
generous patrons who make this channel
possible if you'd like to support the Y
files consider becoming a member on
patreon or picking up President t-shirt
right there are links below that's gonna
do it but until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you